the jurogan experience
when did you decide that you were gonna
do this 14 peaks thing and then film
this and like what was what was the
moment where this idea came into your
head
so jody obviously you got you asked me
two questions let me break down so
2019
um at this point
i've served with the uk special forces
for 10 years
i've been around the world i have
obviously done some crazy [ __ ] you know
that you know people only probably see
on the movies and all that
so what happened in 2019 was
i found the purpose
and uh look just to just to even put
things into perspective
at this point i had served 16 years in
the british military
i had only six years left to get the
full pension
so
you know
so if you look from the the financial
perspective
you know i'm really there to get the
full pension but then i got this idea
like the 14 picks so
why i'm doing this so
i had two purpose the first one was
look doesn't matter where you come from
what your background is whatever that is
you can literally show the world nothing
is impossible no excuses
and the second one was
look
the nepalese climbing community the
serpas are
the king of a thousand us but we never
had the right you know like
credits and i wanted to raise the name
of the nebulous climbers and those two
purpose
gave me the strength so what happened
after that was
straight away i went to the hr
i put my resignation
and people went mentally like you know
my brother is specifically like
names
you know what you're so selfish because
at this point
i used to send
you know a chunk of my salary
every month to my mom and dad i really
believe that
in our parents you know they look after
us when we're like kids and vulnerable
and as a kid back to them when they get
older they're also in vulnerable they
cannot work and all that so
i was always you know like sending them
money so
when i when i decided about this project
and when i put the resignation i know
that there's no money going to them my
brother went really mental is like names
you know you are the the most strongest
financial contributor in our family and
you know what
none of the girls have ever been there
you should you should complete your
career and i was like
no brother and and we didn't talk for
three months
me and my brother and he's like my
father he's the one who sent me to
boarding school i'm going to slow you
down here you so you had this idea and
because of this idea you decided to
resign yeah
and this idea of climbing the 14 peaks
when it first came into your head what
was your goal it was just to elevate the
nepalese climbers was it to raise money
was it to raise awareness
no so it was again literally
to show the world that nothing is
impossible there's no excuses but that's
but that's not a career right so you're
winning you're quitting your career to
show the world
that nothing is impossible i i didn't
only quit my career my brother i put
everything on the line
and and i'll go in details what i mean
by that so
i resigned
and
it was really tough
um
look
i came from this completely different
world special forces background i had
never experienced of doing the
fundraising
and
when i first talked you start talking
about the project people were like
nymphs
it's not possible so for those people
who doesn't understand what i was trying
to do was
so there are 14
mountains in the world above 8 000
meters and 8 000 meters is is the death
zone peak
and the fastest
excuse me 8 000 meters is what it's it's
a dead zone
so the reason why it's called destiny is
from that altitude nobody can survive
the human body is literally dying
so that's why it's called the destroying
peak because all those 14 are ever a
thousand meters so you can only be up
there for a very small amount yeah yeah
and uh so the fastest time was
a week sort of eight years to be precise
it was
seven years 11 months and 14 days
and the guy who tried to break that
record broke it only by one week
so that was that was that and then
i said i will do that in seven months
and people were like
no it's impossible again
you know those guys who are listening
just to put this into simple perspective
so
if the record for a full marathon
is now two hours
what i was saying there then was i'm
gonna do that in ten minutes
and that's why nobody believed in and
and so it was crazy and i used to wake
up at like four o'clock
write the email
take early train to london
meet all this you know
entrepreneurs in the corporate
organization piece them
repeat the same thing come back home
quick food then i write again and the
follow-up email hey nice to meet you
today and you know follow-up email
let me stop you there hold on so you
have this idea you don't have any
experience in filmmaking you don't have
any experience in the media you have no
experience in doing anything in the
public eye no everything you've done has
been just grinding
as a gurkha grinding as a
special forces operator this is what
you're doing and then you just decide
i'm going to do this and i want to make
a movie about it
yeah so yeah who do you contact how do
you even start that process
yeah so it was it was tough so the first
thing was to get the money to to go and
climb so how did you even know how much
money you needed um so you know the high
altitude mountaineering is is quite
expensive let's say even if somebody
want to do this the whole 14 picks um
it will roughly cost around two millions
two million two million dollars and
because i was going as a very like bare
minimum because i don't need that much
support you know i put roughly under a
million margin and you know what brother
nothing there was no funding after one
year of like going everywhere and then
what i did the first thing was
when you say go everywhere like how do
you even start you know like i don't
have any experience in that so i don't
know who would i contact to
fund a giant project where i'm going to
climb 14 peaks i'll just give you this
example
so
one of the example was you know i wrote
a hand written later to
um who is the owner of virgin i google
it
richard branson yeah yes
and you know i had i write that in a
very long later full hand return and i i
cover that and put the
put those in the stamp so that you know
it will you know
going to get his attention and nothing
came
so i was just going after everything
anything from outdoor companies
outdoors and this is already after
you've already quit your job i have
already quit so i have already made the
decision
and that's why it was so stressful
because
now
all my family are suffering because of
my decision
my poor wife she was like you know and
my for the first time you know like
i had to
suffer through this kind of you know
like distress look man you know i have i
have done hr i have been debated all
over the world
i have operated in very like that that
split seconds kind of you know like
environment where your decision has to
be like bombers and and that doesn't
stress me out but here it was mental my
eyes how are you making a living this
was like that how are you making money
so at this point we did we didn't have
money yeah no money so how are you
eating how are you paying your rent so
whatever we had of it of saving
and all that it was there so you were
burning through your savings while
trying to achieve this goal yeah yeah
and so what was the first thing that hit
that let you know that this is possible
because i believed in it no no that's
not what i mean what was the first thing
where someone said yes
where someone said i'll give you money
no so
what happened was
the the funding was really really
struggling and what i did was you know
what people don't believe it because
of course in their eyes you know like
what even red bull says it's like
swimming to the moon
you know so even when they say things
like that so of course you know people
were like oh it's too much tough then
what i did was i remortgaged my house
and put
every money i can put into this project
and that was like only like less than
i would say seven percent of the whole
funding and this is before anybody's
contributed yeah yeah so you have no
investors nothing
you don't even have netflix forget
netflix and i'll come into that story
later on brother so
at this point
and eventually i started doing go
funding i had like no social media so in
march 2019
when i resigned from the special forces
i had no idea but i didn't even have
facebook instagram anything nothing
nothing so i had to learn how to do this
all this hashtag and everything my it
would
it will drive me nuts do you do all your
social media now is still yes so you
reached out to me from social media
that's actually you yeah because i never
know
i'm like this might be something
yeah so i never know because i i think
it might be some
assistance somewhere
yeah i i have a team now but i still i
still you know do my thing because
that's for you it's authentic i do too i
do i do my thing too wow yeah wow
so going back into that one joe what i
really believed in was
okay people doesn't believe now but if i
start climbing this mountain in the
manor and in the style that i said i
would do it
it's going to be possible so
i took the flight to nepal with 15 of
the funding then there were a bit of
like in a small like you know um i would
say sponsorship came in
a few money from gofundme and at that
point when i fly to nepal i had 15 of
the total funding so the first mountain
i choose was annapurna
so in andhrapuna is like where
every four climbers who tried to climb
three dice trying so that was my first
mountain
and you know what this was the first
time ever in the history of my home you
said every four climbers three die yeah
isn't it every four climbers one die no
that's not on annapurna this is that's a
reason
this is an appropriate that's k2 so
most people die
yeah jesus so this is like that's your
first one first one and this month so i
guess if you were gonna die you're gonna
die quick let's let's get it over with
that's so nuts what now what are they
dying from are they dying from from
avalanches it's the mountain where you
see like you know like avalanche is
crumbling every like you know every that
is so crazy every four climbers three
die yeah
that sounds so insane
my that's that's crazy that mountain and
uh jamie's looking it up right now he's
freaking out too
no one's quicker looking [ __ ] up than
jamie by the way yeah yeah and you know
what this mountain you know the big
thing what i was trying to say joe was
how do you spell that mountain it's
annapurna annapurna annapurda yes
so how many people have climbed it all
told
i'm not gonna lie i have no clue here it
goes
32 percent
there have been fewer than 200 summits
of the mountain and 61 people have lost
their lives so it's not quite that much
no you know what because
i changed that statistics in 2019 when i
went there and set the fixed lines with
my team
more than i think 50 people submitted in
2019 right but here's the stat every
three people reach the top one person
dies so you got it reversed
that makes more sense
okay it's closer i think it's i think
that's but you know what it's still very
very dangerous
it's not like it's less impressive okay
you know what joe i'm not going to argue
on that but it's funny jamie he's a
wizard i'm telling you
in last two years um i think there are
around 80 summits
i'm i can't believe there's one but what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people stay
home
so that that that is insane though that
that many people die yeah yeah and you
know underpinnings and you know what
this was
probably the first time in my history
where i was out of my shape because
every energy i had was on the computers
writing email and i was oh you're out of
shape as you see on the movie um i was
10kg heavier i hadn't trained at all
and i was like you know what you have an
insane cardio that's one of the things
from the movie that was so evident you
have very very unusual cardio
um
do you think that some of that is uh
you're just
so do you think that's from the training
that you had when you were a young boy
do you think you just like made yourself
have insane cardio from those runs you
did when you were 16 years old because
when they were doing that vo2 max test
on you yeah that's insane man i mean
your cardio is like elite of the elite
yeah i think it's it's that muscle
memory you know where i have been i have
been training you know since i was kid
and you know like non-stop and obviously
which you know we discussed earlier i
think that's what
what it it made me who i am today um you
know the hard work that the training and
training and training
um but joe you know like a lot of people
think probably you know like oh yeah
nims is from nepal he's from the
mountains and and he climbed all this
peak you know i grew up
in the most flat
and the hottest part of nepal how flat
is it
like almost like in a sea level and it
is like it's
40 45 degrees hot
celsius oh that's very hot that's very
hot even the flies would die on the road
yeah what is 45 degrees celsius that's
like a hot googly buddy
i want to say that's like 110.
is it higher yeah 113. 113 it's crazy
mate and it's that hot sometimes you
know it's like sea level